[Music]
you create the narrative
i am metahuman
[Music]
initial spark for demanding human idea
was
just the fascination with digital
characters in cg
to us digital humans are something
magical even
and you know infinitely complicated
automatic human creator is a cloud
stream application
that lets anybody create high fidelity
digital characters
what used to take months now takes
minutes and people don't even have to
think about all the technical steps that
they normally would need to take
we're going after three really hard
problems and we're not compromising on
any of those
outright quality that you'd expect in a
triple a game for a digital human
making sure that anyone can use this
tool that anyone can create a character
in minutes or hours that used to take
weeks and months and all of that has to
work at that fidelity with
rigged and ready to animate in engine in
real time
this topic previously reserved only for
teams with large budgets and a large
amount of time
now is accessible to everybody and even
to people outside of the industry
it's like really a very robust but very
simple to use
system and it's really a joy when you
just sit there in front of the tool and
you can just like
focus yourself on the sheer creativity
and and
get excited about exploring
the metahuman creator uses a library of
real scans of people
so when you move the handles around to
create a character you're mixing
together these different parts
of real people to create something
that's still really believable and
lifelike and has personality
but it's not just creating the shape of
the face you can also choose wrinkles
applied to the face to make a character
look older
but we're not just applying this as a
texture onto the face we also subtly
change the geometry of the face at the
same time to make sure those wrinkles
really match with the shape of the face
and just bring the whole thing together
into a realistic and believable
character
one of the really cool features that you
get out of the box with the human
creator is that
you're essentially focused on creating
the high quality character but
at the same time you get multiple levels
of details
we take the hugely detailed strand based
hair and turn that into card based groom
and then into a simple helmet we take
the geometry of the face and make
simplified versions of that
we also simplify the materials so that
you can use these characters
in a crowd or on a range of different
devices
it's also creating a new rig for the
character which controls how they move
how they emote and that really brings
life to the character
and then there's this other moment when
you hit play and it comes to life
and that's really the benefit of being
real time and always generating this
fully rigged
version of the face is you hit play and
it moves it's alive
and this person who's come from your
imagination that doesn't exist in real
life
is suddenly there looking at you smiling
at you that is kind of magical
when you look at methuen creator or
things we're doing with quicks or mega
scans
the things that are coming in unreal 5 i
think the type of content we're going to
see from very small teams and
individuals is going to be a massive
shift
human can be your endpoint it can be the
character that goes into your game
but it can also be your starting point
where you start creating
your own layers on top of what metahuman
provides
i feel that we've accomplished something
truly remarkable here
by creating these digital characters
with which
you can empathize our whole team spent
years
designing this database in these rigs
and we're so excited to give this back
to the community around the world
[Music]
you